each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
in previous session arm Kobe talk about
the overview of the windows azure us you
have already seen the Windsor has many
different components different stories
from the infrastructure service to
preference survey sir in my session I
will I would discuss the wings as a
virtual machine I choose the virtual
machine is very fundamental also very
key services on wind session my name is
Larry my name is David Young I'm sitting
program manager in China crowd
Innovation Center ccic probably some of
the some of you already know the
Microsoft has different kind of solution
offering for different scenario from the
private cloud to public crowd maybe you
still remember the curb you mentioned
the ecosystem their approach in the
ecosystem was public clouds of Windsor
private crowdin babe its many based on
the windows server and system center
also we had the service provider so no
matter what can the technology won't use
actually the Microsoft has the US has
provided some corresponding the offering
and solution for example from the
physical machine to virtual machine to
ice well actually held question or you
guys how many of you have used the
virtual machine before all the matter
what kind of many of it guys okay so
what kind of technology use when will
help of a citrix just make some noise
when well okay okay well Wimmer is where
Association pretty popular in private
cloud in hyper-v hypervisor
virtualization those those area what
today we're too about the infrastructure
as a service infrastructure service is
now just a virtualization as your
virtualization is very basic
component in the infrastructure services
as well you're wrong we'll have you your
own voice transition you have wronged
you you have to manager the physical
machine and the virtual machine
everything everything about that but if
you're the infrastructure service that
you don't need to worry about the
infrastructure it only the bar about the
network networking storage computing
what are you where you need to do is
just a provision provision of VN that's
what we're all you need to do so on when
we talk about the cloud computing may be
armed you are simple welker computing
sensor is very high-tech it's only seen
to do with me I should scrub computing
from and users perspective it's not that
well I'd say it's not like the rocket
science it's as simple as 123 as you
will see on Windows Azure as user you
the first thing you need to do is just
to pick up the way you are provisioning
your vm you create a VM there's a couple
ways you can do but first way is if you
if you are new comer I give a new
comment on the winds asian may be
properly you are selected management
portal because many photo has the better
UI has very user-friendly you front
portal you can provision of en if you
are experienced user let's see what you
need to provision VN or manage VN from
time to time properly you will use the
script scripting yours partials Creek
you are no just script you can do some
debris repeal port task job and
scripting also if you are developer or
you have developer in your organization
and your heavy leverage on the windows
azure to provide your research most
likely you are developing your own
solution based on the rest api provided
by windows azure there's three ways once
you decide to what which pro super used
to provision vm the step two is your
select the image and the vm size once
there's two different kinds of the image
on windows azure
one is windows server the other is Linux
obviously then you select to the size of
vm from Ashmore to as Raj as should we
have the three additional because a
large memory skill where talk about
later is from a five to a c7 after you
select the VM image and vm sighs you
just click create the windows azure were
provisional vm for you it just takes a
couple minutes then you will have your
vm running the vm the Disco is running
in the wings to edge of storage it's a
persistent disk that only worried about
the date lost well I will give you a
quick demo on how to create a VN and
with Azure USA how easy it is
well as you can see this is portal is
this a Windsor management portal phones
portal I can see all the items under my
subscription if I want to create the VN
what I need to do is just click new
compute a selective virtual machine I
use a quick crate I'll give it a name
let's see i triple e demo1 i select
image do you remember with a different
kinds of image that's windows image
that's or Linux image let's see i pick
up the other image is Windows Server
2008 r2 image then select size phones
actual small to a seven I use a small
size I give the administrator username
here
was in the password
then actually create a VM then you are
CR from the status bar you'll find that
the vm is in creating then after a
couple minutes so we come back you are
see the VMA is running let's go back my
deck well as you can see on the Chris
vien dong Windsor is super easy just one
two three yes that's it what one select
a different image you finds as a bunch
of image image over there windows server
also some different kinds different
different types linux image there right
now on Windows Azure we support the some
limited distribution of the email of
Linux image we support the suse open
suse we support the centos you poon to
also the Oracle Linux on the
organization well maybe you ask this
question how about if I want to use the
image for example I want to use the
sensuous 6.4 that image is not available
on Windows Azure what I can do well
actually you can preview your own linux
image you can do that the problem but
there's two things you need to take to
care one is your master installs a
integration component that's actually
it's the wind sensor agent in your image
where you can get to Vince as a male
agent from the our website or from the
open source community to the agent is
open source in service open source the
second things is if you use you ate you
if you use your own image we are not
provide support for that image that
means if the imager has some problem you
have to chop shooting by yourself
otherwise if you use the image / in the
gallery are provided by our partner so
you can get the support for example
Susie if you Susie image know where were
provide the support
different from the other Microsoft
product software-as-a-service Windsor is
very open for the open source software
as you can see our on wins danger the
Linux is the obviously it's the first
class member or first class family
member on the windows azure right now
Unwin cetera we have more exams and
price as free as you can see mostly
image from our partner actually it's our
partner to responsibility to provide
image and support the image those image
movers on end price but we are also very
open we have to provide the image from
the community open source community
center is the example actually essential
OS is a very active community in China
also in the worldwide so we we also
provide the send us image in our gallery
supports as I mentioned the image
support is provided by our panel for
example for the sensuous is provided by
the open object to see is provided by
the veil after you pick up the right
image the things things you need think
about is what kinda size what size of
the vm i want to use well when you
select different size different
different vm sighs which means the
couple seems first different size of the
vm means that the different number of
the course you can use in that VN the
things one is a different size of a
memory also different size of vm means
the difference has been with well i
actually dependent whiskey right away
only controlled open all boundaries not
inbound damage that means if you had two
VMs what vm one is the extra-large vien
vien to its axis bo vien but as you can
see as Raj vm has a hundred neck base
bandwidth as just more vm head loss it's
a bad example i say v m2 is the small vm
a small v
has only 100 megabits bandwidth but if
you transfer data from the vm 12 v m2 as
you can have the benefits up to a
hundred because we only control the
outbound bandwidth now inbound besides
the extra small to extra large we have
three red unique the vm sizes that's
from the a5 287 if I 287 we call its
large memory skill much memory means to
as you can see from the a5 we only have
two costs but it had 14 K by memory a 78
cost but has 56 k pi memory what this
kind of vm can be used on some de memory
incentive scenario for example database
as we as we all know debates were
consumed nozzle memory so in that case
you can use a file or e7 vm sighs what I
just general house create vm is very
simple but you may have this question
what happened if I just what I need to
provision the 100 and say I'm even the
Sultan's VMs how can I manager those VMs
what happened if I need the do some the
load balancing or make sure the hive
ability of my vm how can I control them
well Chris vm is very simple but if you
want you have very complex deployment
for example if I you have project on
NASA and lotsa project maybe you need to
the hundreds of the vm you will have to
think about the load balance and
mobility in that case we provide some
advanced feature you can you can
leverage to manage your vm the first one
is cross tourism
the cross service is used to you can
organize the vm you can group your VN in
krauser is what cross tourism means one
crossover is that we provide one public
IP to that cross service if the group
the VN in cross service that means those
group of VN were shared one public IP
well maybe you'll have questioned why i
need to group those vm in the group
across service the reason is in cross
services we can provide some advanced
features like the load balancer you can
have the multiple VN i can do put the
english in one load balancer set let's
see those VMs are or web server yeah in
the same web behind the load balancer
you do the load balancer for those VMs
so those reason must have it must be in
the cross service auto if you want to
make sure the hive ability of the OV
ends for example you had two VMs you
won't make sure those VMs not in the one
photo main well photo may are basically
you can simply dr. photo mean like the
rack okay we want to put the VNA
different brag that means they
definitely there in the different
physical machine they are different in
the user difference which is use the
different power supply so in that way if
the one rack is cooked it's going down
that's no impact on my business because
I my vm across different wreck okay if
you want organize your vm in RAC a
different brag or different photo may
you have to use the across service in
cross service so you can specify which
domain and which domain they are in the
one vibrated set we're top out the top
of that data well here is a example
example in this example we have the
different tiers of the server VMs this
is the front frontier we have fro web
server we put for web server and the
2-pack and server this database servers
those six servers in one cloud service
in this one cross ovation we had the two
well actually we had the true everybody
set one is
for the web server wines for Table seven
also you can put the for web server
behind the load balancer that means the
end user you can access the one public
IP is to the HTTP or HTTPS and point
then you can they can access the four or
for instance by wrong robbing also we
have this application may depend on some
infrastructure we so we have another
walk across service the cross servicer
is used to provide the infrastructure
for the Holy Roman the infrastructure
including next atomic controller DNS of
some other network service
infrastructure ways we put the
infrastructure service in in a separate
cloud service if you need to create the
connection between your deployment on
Azure and you your own data center as
you can create the VPN turn on between
the windows azure and your taste injure
you this is a VPN I this is actually the
ipsec VPN turn on so in that case we can
do that let's see the Active Directory
replication between the windows azure
and your tone 10 centers to make on
Shola do something replication between
the so in that case and should this sub
this virtual network is just a pretty
much like the remote office or one over
one of your other subsidiary in your
network so it's a part of your network
actually so this is our example how we
use a cloud service our load balancer to
leverage those other ones feature when
we deploy or use the virtual network
we'll talk about the load balancer let's
look at the ability I just mentioned
that some of the concept that's a for
domain update domain well what if the
first time for you to hurt this term you
you can just replace further me with the
rack is there pretty much like you can
see it is there it's a rack so when we
put you can you had the option what when
we talk about the availability we have
to talk about Islam so this level image
on with session we provide the
ninety-nine point nine five percent of
the straw for the multiple instance so
what exam a word exactly means that the
mobile instance the multiple instances
you have the multiple VMS those VMS they
perform the same function you put those
VMS in one availability set if the web
research has more than two instance
where the winds edge can guarantee is a
ninety nine point eight ninety-five
percent straw fought for that service
just in this case we have two instance
to VMS in one of a bit instead as i
mentioned when you put the multiple
instance in whatever we set the wind
sensor web controller they are the rest
mar is smart enough to know we are put
away place the VN indifferent wreck okay
well those drum means your arm sorry
let's go back what natural means are the
telecenter level and the hardware lever
the some time is it including that the
straw that means that 99.95 percentage
of the straw means we have we can only
done the for run four hour watch one
year therefore was four hours including
the or the hardware failure theories in
the video also including the hardware
upgrade
how's the operating system patching
those kind of stuff so what's not
included in the Astra the vm level the
issue for example if your vm has a has
its own set for example do your turret
some very important files or you crash
the vm those kind of the issue is now
including in strong what a village that
is the arm for the vmware we simplify
the photo main update domain those kind
of concept in the available in the
everybody set of a preset is you put the
different sim drawers here in touch
information service web server this web
server one web server to the other
performed this they are they take the
sim road they are the same functionality
so we regrouped in a very set of the
sequel server we had to tell bit server
they do they can mirroring all the they
are used some other ones legs are always
on cluster so you grew those secret
server instance in your vape reset so
right now we had to a bit set in that
case the webcam webcam children no tap
controller is the is a management stack
in Windows Azure the web control were
smart enough to know we are put that if
these two VMs in different photo me just
like fold put in that different rack the
rack is flow domain in some case also
besides the photo may we also know we
are put the different VN in the
different update domain update on update
on being so you know because we're used
to the wall the VMG running another
physical machine we need to patch in the
physical machine we need to replace some
of the hardware components so definitely
a physical machine need to shut down for
maintenance so how how we shut down the
fatima simple has no impact on your
virtual machine the way as we organize
the vm in the in the foot in the vapor
set and also in the
domain in that case this VM web server
one web server to they are in the same
web research the they were building in a
different update domain which means we
are not update these two servers at the
same time we are a range different
schedule for the different materials for
those VMs house um that's a vapor that
means what they are putting a different
photo me and different update domain
let's look at the example of how we
designed the very compressed deployment
on the Windows Azure you had the two web
server you have to secrecy over there do
the leverage the sick of mirroring to
provide a higher vibrating in that case
we organized the sequel server in one
availability search that's the Seco dash
AV set we are organized at the true web
server in your separate a vibrator set
as the I stash every edge we also put
the true web server behind the load
balancer so in in that case the user
will access the public IP and load
balancer and then redirect to the
different this instance well let me do a
quick demo on how how to use the load
balancing and the hive ability
well we can first a look at the on the
vm we just create this is a i triple e
demo 1vn it's the windows server 2008 r2
vm after the vm create you have the
notification here says successfully
create a VM I to be demo1 it here's
detail and just click OK skip the
notification then I can click the vm you
will have the first dashboard view give
you a summary of the vm lecture which IP
use which the popular IP in which the
private IP also saw some performance
data lie sir excuse me no sir um disk
performance memory cpu networking all
those infrastructure our metrics here
also you can you can you can see this is
a house hostel name this is a dns name
that means the vm is running on windows
azure you can access the vm from the
front internet and you just use this at
the ends name you can access it this
deal this vm has the public virtual IP
well internally you use the internal IP
its private IP ok let's ipu us see from
the vm itself but this IP public IP is
you you end user your user use the IP to
access the service ok as the
administrator now i can connect actually
connect we are open the RDP remote
desktop remote desktop connection file
well I cannot move my mouse
ok click open
click connect now I just in nature and
import my juice username and password
the username and password is one I I
said one act right to vm maybe you're
still remember what's the name what's
the username do you remember Larry's ash
okay passport I can I never tell you a
passport okay okay
you
what this is a vm that running on
Windows Azure I show you can also
provisions a Linux VM while you have the
user let's turn out order choose connect
the vm as shows a 22 port well i create
this VN y yo maybe you will see I didn't
configure an across ovation I didn't
come fix the load balancer or the other
bridge set the reason is actually that
true wizard happy recruit vm y is a
quick crate quikrete means your skip
lots of settings just use it by default
default settings in the divan by default
if you use the quick create it will
create a separate class away so for the
vm just cry here's crossways as you can
see there's two class service one is a i
triple e demo 0 1 a demo 1 this is the
cross of it which is one crate vnd
creates the crops across all for that vm
the other cross servicer is a car Chung
is mine are named if you look at the V
this V n the starter is this
cross-division Yasim I should the
service has multiple instance here a to
instance why is called our windows
server 2008 r2 one is called win Stuart
Roosa 2012 r2 to instance so I group
those two VMs in one cross service then
I can as I mentioned in that in this
case we can use the load balancer we can
use the we can complete everybody set
for the for the for these two VMs let's
first look at the load balancer ok right
now if I clicked the 2008 r2 there's
page car endpoints n point means it's
pretty much like firewall ok you create
a VN on the on the windows azure by
default we vm k
only open a very limited support on the
on fire walk under our load balancer now
well let's look at the new decree vm
Nestor I to be demo if you look at the
end point here you have only to end
point open one is for the power sure the
answer is for the remote desktop the
post of the two endpoints are only used
for the remote management what happens
if I I used actually I true beauty mo
maybe it's the web server so what do you
need to do it's a web server can access
the web server for instance right now no
of course not why I i do have endpoint
here so i need to do is I add a new
endpoint ok i created the stand on end
point i create a nice say protocol is
the tcp protocol sorry way i can name
here maybe why do the i just use the
default name it's a HTTP the public
power is a day the private power is 80
that means where i will open the 80 TCPA
deport on the firewall so after i create
the endpoints this user can fro can
access the I Triple E demo1 from the
internet through the HTTP protocol I
skip this part let's go back to the lair
easy it there well let's go back to the
here I have two instance here one is
2008 r2 this one has three endpoint one
is HTTP and you well it's it's not just
a seminal edge it's tough it's not just
not not just a simple endpoint actually
this is a load balancer I create a load
balancer the little person were
listening on the tcp port 80 right now
if I look at the other instance this
instance has only the default end point
there's no it don't balance or tea HTTP
port down and point them so this is my
dns name right so jung
doc appt done that i refresh this one I
got the page the page is default page of
the windows server 2008 r2 because
Windows Server 2008 r2 is the is-7 now
what I I would do right now is our
Creator I will create that new end
points on the windows server 2008 sorry
to say I'm just on some 12 are to create
new endpoint here this Empire join the
this instance to the load balancer let's
see how can we do this I I set this
option at the end point to an existing
load balancer set I have a little band
says it's a load Larry everyone then i
create a given name HTTP let's see ARP
one I don't need to reconfigure a load
balancer I just used the original
setting okay click OK complete then you
are Syria we have the new endpoint here
this endpoint is also part of the load
balancer set after the update complete
will refresh this page you will see
sometimes your redirect to the i7 page
sometimes work to redirect me to the
windows server 2012 r2 instant
information server page that's amazing I
seven eyes nine or ten i don't remember
examine well I took just one or two
minutes
again here at the status bar you can see
what happening right now and it's
complete of the field
okay it's done its success rate at
endpoint to the my new instance now let
me refresh let's take the page as you
can see it's a run going so well
refreshed page it's redirect me to the
new page is this new instance use the
Windows Server 2012 r2 so this is the
new homepage okay that's a little
balancer let's look at everybody set
on hvm you can see well you can convict
the lib reset you can use the existing
of a pizza or you can create a new /
preset for example right now I have to
just two instance in this crowd service
this those these two instance are
opposed to the web server so i created a
bib result for them in the previous
example we have for VMS to web server to
teddys server so in that case i just i
can create the new avebe set for the
deepest layer dip it still so in that
case we have one cross service to of a
preset okay let's go back to the cross
service you will see when I I put the
two instance in the same crowd
Cinderella princess so you are find
those two instance well we put in the
difference update domain and a different
and different photo main see here so
let's good
we are in a different what what we in
the different update domain when we
supposed should be in the four different
fold up photo made easier not sure maybe
some people just change the
configuration let's go back to this one
and config maybe i'll just create the vm
this morning it then they take some time
to move to the difference for domain so
you can see we had leverage the load
balancer and a vibrate set to to manager
have ability and the manager the
performance load balancer so if you
create a new vm you can use the doesn't
love the quick crate you can use
provision from the gallery if your
provision from the gallery you have the
many advanced settings Troy you have the
more choice neck so which crossovers you
want to join which represent you will
use from here you can select the
different image including the image
introduction here for example right now
I can create a new less essential as
image open logic centos 6.3 acting next
I'll give the name Archie ye demo to
also it's a small small one you can
select upload the ssh key or you can
create a part provide create a password
in the password then create next
well this page I had the more more
choice here against their to join the
different different cloud service I can
select join the I i triple e demo one
cross service because i joined this
cross away so it put me in the way i can
also select the different storage
counter i want to use on my mark richt
we will talk about the storage later on
so i skip this part you can see we can
create a libra cell here because i
triple e of a bit set you a call next
you can create the different endpoint
here or you can just live here is by the
44 only open the 22 tcp port for the
management for the remote manager ok
create so after this vm create you r CI
trooper UTM 0 1 the cross always will
have the mothball instance here only one
where when this will create complete you
have the two instance here you can
configure the balancer you can configure
a very sad those other ones feature here
let's are what I want demoed the load
balancer and the of a preset let's go
back to my deck
ok
after your vm courage you must deal with
some of the resource in the in the vm
when you could vm patty for it will give
the two disc one you had the actual you
have default compressor have two disc
one is OS disc no matter is your windows
server OS or NSO v and os you will have
the OS disk operating system is
installed on this disk or actually
depends on the depend on the operating
system if you use windows server
operating system you will get the 127 k
patch OS disk if you use the Linux
operating system you got the Saudi King
Biogen disk well what what in case M if
you need the mode this OS disk space
where you can do what you can you can
create your own image you can create
your image you can use the hyper-v to
create your own linux image and you
upload image to the windows azure you
can provision vm from your own image
what the salt married well let's take
the type a sector disk is the temporary
storage as just answer is i just like
the name tears it's the temporary
storage is not persistent storage well
actually this story is that it's the
disco in the Hosmer seen nor in the
azure storage that means if your VMs we
move from the one house machine to
another host machine the content in that
desk we are we lost so it's not
persistent disk it's just before the
temp it's just for the temporary use but
that disco might have some benefits for
you the first benefit is about this
contagion see one OS disk and other
discs are all still in the remote
storage so when you access those disco
the disco might provide the better IOPS
i 0 per second but the disconnect didn't
say might be might be of concern for
example the discs are running the
wincest origin you access this data from
the front of vm to that disc the disc
and this then maybe well in some case
maybe more than 20 millisecond so for
some application it's ok for but for
some other application that might be
concerned so in that case you can
leverage the local disk to see if some
was some of the data which needs the
load disk religion see you can use the
temporary disk what again the
temperature is now for the persistent
data so it's only for temperatures we
have to besides the OS disk and
temperature we have the cert type it's a
tilt disk the tempo the typical you can
have you can have the moat about the
disk if you remember when I talk about
the different sizes of the VN I
mentioned different size vm means the
different crawls on different memory
there's also one scene is different is
the number of the telescope can be
attached to the vm for example if you
have the extra vm you can attach up to
the 16th the disk if you use those extra
small you use the small VN you can only
you can only attach the one disk so
net-net is different also the folded it
is is can up to 1 terabyte for the
storage in addition for H the dead disco
we can prove we can give you the 500
iops the performance so well let's do a
very simple calculation so what in case
you need the let's say the non-jew i'm
sorry/not 9000 IOPS how many disks you
need to attach the vm 16 so you need
extra large vm to attach cysteine deity
ESCA to provide your 9000 chayo PS or OS
disk and a desk are they had the catch
catch setting but they had the default
value for example OS disco the catcher
it is it enabled by default but for dead
disco you can control your endeavor cash
or not what in most cases or in a pasar
our experience based on your experience
maybe it was definitely shouldn't need
enable cash but this might be not sure
imagine the reason is what the cash on
Asian cash on the cash on the disco be
actually means two things one is a sum
of cash it's in the memory what that
speeds very fast the very camp in
improving performance but some cash on a
local disk of the host machine so let's
see in some case you're you need cash
loss of data the dinner is larger than
the memory cache so you have to leverage
the local tease on the host machine as
we all know the local disks on host
machine cannot provide the same IOPS
level as a Windsor storage so in that
case you in neighbor cache cannot
improve your performance not just cannot
improve actually even can be worse so I
was just as if you are very only a small
theater and I see very small tips
motivates you can enable cash but you
had very large Davis that's more than
10k by Jay bass join up to not enable
cash okay this is a this is the best
parent she's sharing of course you can
you can also try to enable/disable and
the test performance then get the pastor
of best compression for yours narrow for
your for your for your case that's the
cash the cheshire we'll talk about that
cash setting besides the temperate
Dayton temporary temper disk the OS disk
and 30s Garros store in the windows
azure storage the windows azure storage
is the persistent storage as you we have
the three core base in the winter
session storage so from the Williams as
a running
the first from the first day which says
run into today with never lost an engine
never so this is a very reliable as you
probably know if you we have this recopy
for the for the data actually durability
is a more than 11 9 besides the locals
to recover a you can even have the
option to enable the work of the treat
geography replication that means you
will have another story Corps Base in
the remote is engine Commission could be
mentioned we were reputed this danger we
group this into in different region for
example in the Asia we have to TA Center
in Singapore in Hong Kong Singapore Hong
Kong t simpler there we see they are in
the same region so these two station
though they were do the GG replication
for each other so if you enable the geo
replication on your storage count you
have the six Cobra in total straight in
local story local did center
straightening remotely center we will
make sure that those two days enters is
a far away from each other more than 500
miles so just in case the Vienna is the
host machine running vm is going down we
are start a new instance from the
another host machine the host machine
will pick up the data in the storage
winsor storage and continue running the
vm for you we have talked about the disc
then let's have a look at the image as i
mentioned actually we provide a bunch of
image you can also create your own image
by yourself for example you have
different ways to create the image the
first free is a you can you can run you
can set up a hyper-v in your environment
in your datacenter then you can install
the linux or windows server on the
unhappy then your juices prepare your
juicer wizardy provision the wrong in
those agents then you're saved vht and
upper virtually to the witness a sure
that you can provision the vm based on
those image the second approach that
approach is you create VN from the our
get pizza
official image then you'll customize
your image sorry customize your vm then
you'll capture the VN as a as your image
yes to approach well this is the first
we are you create your own image from
your data center your upload to the
crowd upload to windsor storage then you
can create the vm from that from that
image that's uploading created LVN
that's once you need to you need to take
care if you upload the image to the one
storage account you can only the
provision vm things that storage count
you can add a selector storage come you
remember just now I create a VM I create
a second vm the I Triple E demo to I had
the option to select which storage
counts i will put the vm m if you could
provision vm by from your own image you
can now select the storage count that
means if you want to praise the VN in
different storage count you have to
upload different image in different
storage count its first way I bring your
image the same way is your create image
from the crowd that's you had you
already had the vm the prevention the vm
from the official image in the gatorade
then you put your pull vm you customize
the VN and your do some the generalized
a nice arm sis prepare or window sash
the provision then you kept to the vm
after kept a vm the vm received in the
storage cons they later you can
provision vm based on that base on that
image well i will show you how to
capture the vm
well I have I to V ends here and I see I
had the I let's see i have do some
customization work on the demo 2 so 4
demo to USC i had the option here it's
the capture well i need for sure I
suppose I do some that the provision job
here I shut down the VN after a shot on
VN you the capture the capture parting
will now create anymore so I can use the
crap church kept to the vm as image
besides the capture stops stop you have
of other option next whether that's the
wrists are and you can also attach disco
attach tix means you're attached to disk
choose a vm you can attach more about
did this because it depends on the size
of vm you can actually you can also
change the size of vm but anytime you
change the size vm it need to restart
the vm for example for this VN we use
the small size actually we can change to
the let's say a 7 56 k by memory size
the vm then i click the see after chicks
if it will rest and then the vm will
have varied to super large vm i'll skip
this part ok it's a being shut down then
let's look at the VN well you can see we
can capture the VN as an image it give
the name for the image i say i triple e
image
I have the run that wins the azure
agents are the provision command
actually I didn't but I just the work
around here so after the capture the
image you will have that your only image
right ok let's go back my deck an
awesome let's talk about how to manage
of the vm
that's Caribbean oops well
how to manage a vm well actually a vm is
a pretty simple just like you manage
your virtual machine in your test center
or like to manage your physical machine
yo ta Center you can leverage all the
management tools that you are writing
you are using today for example if you
wanted to do some the monitoring you're
going to the patchy all the solutions
can apply can also be a prior and on
with Azure what you need to do is that
you're either deployed the management
management system window so you can
manage those other VMS you can also you
can also have the option to use your
management server in your day centre and
create a vp internal between the azure
virtual network and you're dead center
in that way you can leverage the
existing management our servers to
manage those VMs
as for the window sashes vm SF it can be
managed by the description on windows to
the script can be used on the windows
windows crimes Mac nearest kind we
support the PowerShell and win server
nodejs are crying command-line interface
on linux but actually the script is a
pretty powerful as can do most
everything you do from the portal well
that's pretty much all in my session we
talked about to experience how we use
the vm how Trivium house manages the
load balancer of a pity set we also
talked about how to create a scan image
and how to manage the vm so yeah it's my
incision next hour past time to my Creek
zoom way here are chopped out the
witness as a storage and see goat a base
yeah that before that let's take the
five minutes shop break thank you